how can they claim there was no
vaccination when Biden had his
pre-inauguration
Biden makes up some facts about when he
got faxed this week the White House
tweeted when President Biden took office
Millions were unemployed and there was
no vaccine available
but as even the most casual political
Observer would note Biden took office
January 20th 2021 at least a month after
he took the covet facts he made a big
deal out of it in fact a month earlier
he tweeted this today I received the
covid-19 vaccine then on January 13th
still a week before he took office the
same Twitter White House Twitter account
posted this video with the caption
president like Brian received his second
dose of the covid-19 vaccine so it
appears they're not even trying to hide
the fact that they're lying meanwhile
Joe's attempt to smear Donald Trump this
week totally backfired during a
Democratic fundraiser he called Trump
the great Maga King
my Republican colleagues say these
programs to help the working class and
middle class people
that's they say that's why we have
inflation
they're dead wrong
under my predecessor
the great maggot King
the deficit increased every single year
he was president
okay first it looks like he's about to
belt out some Sinatra hits
also what he just said it doesn't even
make sense he basically slammed two
disconnected sentences together and then
he gives Trump actually a positive
nickname because it's always a sick burn
to call your enemy a king which then
Trump naturally embraced posting this
Lord of the Rings style Maga King meme
on his own social media platform
truth social gotta say it looks good as
a brunette
so it's another sad Grim week for Old
Joe what's Joe got to say
no no no no it was a good week it's a
good week
that's right because I came up with
nicknames this week all by myself too I
didn't have any help from uh Ron sackey
or Jennifer clean any of those people
that was me I had uh uh ultramaga that
was mine that was mine and uh then just
one day later I came up with the Maga
King I'm doing it man I'm playing the
name game
come on come on I'll do another one
right now A Maga
I'll do it tomorrow
Carly how dumb is he to give Trump a
positive nickname well I know I think
that you know what's really happening is
that Biden is trying to copy Trump
because you can't be doing that I mean
Trump was a master class in childish and
hilarious and effective insults Little
Marco lion Ted crooked Hillary sleepy
Joe we still remember and they like
actually affected their political
careers right Biden doesn't you're
exactly absolutely right no energy jab
that that killed him it killed him he
gives Donald Trump a compliment and the
family loves it I was talking to Laura
Trump on first day she's like thank you
for making me a member of a royal family
I'm I'm like princess Mega now I
appreciate it finally a real royal
family I don't like these crazy people
in California
nutty couple you know Tyrus
that tweet about the vaccinations and
stuff I think the media is finally
feeling like now the White House is just
insulting them because they assume that
the media is not going to fact check
them but now it's like they're going
like okay we saw him get the vaccination
yeah I mean I don't know it might not be
the media I think it's people yeah I
think everyone who's like what yeah I
mean for was it Putin's fault we didn't
have the vaccines yeah because literally
all this Administration does is point
fingers and
anyone can do that I mean even if you
don't have fingers you can just yeah
like that I mean it's not a hard thing
to be like to blame it like every
three-year-old I've ever come across is
phenomenal at blaming somebody else for
something that they did even literally
their filled diaper they'll be like
Daddy did it yes you know what I'm
saying and that's what our
Administration does they have no
Solutions in sight so now every time
they point something out and they lie
about something they have to double down
it's that woke Progressive thing where
we talked about where if you prove it's
a lie they just stretch it and keep it
going like the thing with Trump with the
two Banks yeah well it was obviously two
different banks these guys are very
clever they tricked us so we'll just
keep it going and that's what they're
doing the problem is every time you look
at polling and every time you you hear
American people talk no one's falling
for it there's no curtain they have no
bravado and they're no good at insults I
have never in my life been like look gut
failed you well I guess let me think how
could I do this look King of the little
people
see that sounds good but yeah I like
that you know it's like he's still even
though he's physically underachieving he
stole the highest of his class yes so it
doesn't doesn't really work where am I
cat I would do you have a nickname
none that I can share here
oh my God
would you like a nickname have you
thought of any nicknames for yourself
none that I can share
so isn't it interesting that uh the guy
that claimed a you he wanted to return
to normalcy and want to unify a country
has done neither he's almost created
societal upheaval I mean I feel so it's
terrible about your children not having
baby formula cats I feel so terrible
that I've never met them
so I work too much yeah yeah you work
too much yeah I do it's so nice of you
to leave them in the forest
they're very outdoorsy yeah they're
ready and they made so many friends with
the Wolves yeah the wolves are doing a
great job well they're not out to those
there's a lot of stay raised a lot of
kids those Wolves yeah they can take off
my hands yeah so likewise
Biden just he just keeps talking about
Trump like so this one like for a couple
years I was dating this horrible
horrible man like an actual sociopath
horrible horrible monster did we stopped
dating and I date so I started seeing
this other guy who was stupid and like
everything that he said made me just
like repulsed and disgusted yeah but I
kept him around because I was like oh
he's nice to me yes right A lot of
people voted for Biden just because he
wasn't Trump right and you can only be
like the rebound guy for so long before
you have to offer something else right
or other people are going to be over it
that's a great Point thank you I'm full
of those great point cat that'll be your
nickname that's great that's way better
than I think gpk
gpk killer there we go yeah
sohegs last word to you the great Maga
King yes I can't think of a better name
I know uh the great late night King yes
he'll meet and Ducey fight over the
great morning show
I mean that makes him Donald the great
like Alexander the Great Alfred the
Great how do you think they got those
names they didn't think that's exactly
it Ivan the Terrible he loved that name
he made torture great again exactly
do you really think Ivan was terrible or
did he just get like a Miss like was he
just misunderstood it was disinformation
no he disemboweled everybody
what if he would just Ivan the
disagreeable
it's probably Ivan the slightly miffed
not as strong no so I think we'll go
with Ivan the Terrible I've been the
Misunderstood my yes exactly exactly all
right well I guess we beat this into the
ground what about cats boyfriends
everything yes right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else